money back where post-production I mean
we i mean this is this this is something
that we could get into a very long
conversation about but once you move in
here's the thing there are so many
different scenarios and so many roads
that you can go down but film festivals
cost a lot on my app applying to those
film festivals copies of DVDs some
people want blu-rays once you get into
theaters the the poster costs the
shipping costs the print materials the
DCP conversion which is quite expensive
which then each individual theater needs
their own hard drive with that DCP file
on those hard drives so those are and
those can be very very steep cost for
someone that has no money who's watching
every dollar they spend me pulled from
this imaginary world that doesn't it
doesn't exist i guess or doesn't have
any real real money and and they count
but uh yeah i mean there's there's a
tremendous amount from we got picked up
for a VOD so there's conversion there's
conversion fees and and costs associated
with those captions you have to pay for
captioning for your film ADR work it was
like every corner return it was like
okay that's 3,000 that's yeah oh man so
it adds up you know I mean I you really
have to do your homework if if you want
to get the film out there and we we were
luck we've we've been very lucky
especially for the scale of the film but
and we've met some very key people that
have especially in the distribution
process that have at least lettuce and
some appetizer or a useful or down some
useful Avenue so would you say I mean in
G tips give me some statistic about yeah
i don't i don't remember exactly what
that is but I mean you're for film like
ours to enjoy the the gross majority of
your costs will be and n toestand
holliston is distribution now not all
independent films were like that like i
mentioned before a lot of just in some
of these cases people dumped off a
tremendous amount a more into the
production and then they have no money
for for distribution and then they
either get lucky and down some other
Avenue but I mean there's a million
different scenarios or um and like i
said i would definitely any viewer
looking to to make movie on credit cards
or through funny go to film an attendant
they they have what you need and they
they will educate the filmmaker which is
cool
you